hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the great
insights that we can glean from the work
by Marcus Tullius Cicero called on
friendship is a kind of mistake and its
consequences and a mindset associated
with it that loves things instead of
loving friends and what we've got here
is a fundamentally mistaken way of not
just looking at friendship itself but
understanding values in relation to each
other and understanding the kinds of
things that we are dealing with and and
their possible relations to us and so as
we move into this two key questions that
we should ask ourselves and we can do
this both with this book and when we're
trying to apply this in real life
what does a person actually desire or
love or enjoy what are they effectively
connected with because this will not
only be evident in their decision-making
but this will guide their
decision-making and valuation whatever
it is that they happen to say we look at
what they do and that reveals to us what
they desire and feel and
we can also ask this closely connected
question well what does or why does a
person value a friend
are they valuing them as the person that
they are
are they valuing them in essentially
instrumental ways they can get something
out of the friend
are they valuing them as perhaps an
opportunity for them to love or are they
focused on the love that they're getting
in return these are all very important
questions and they reveal to us the
character and mindset of a person and
their capacity to enjoy that that
relationship that Cicero calls pure and
perfect friendship the genuine sort of
friendship that is based on a deep
abiding connection with the other person
based in a kind of Accord involving
goodwill and indeed affection with the
other so first we should look at scipios
criticism now Scipio of course was
Laelius the the narrator's great friend
and indeed superior in many respects and
he he tells us that this is a bit of an
aside here but it's actually quite quite
a good one he says that I often recur to
Cicero Mississippi Oh my sole authority
for a discourse on friendship he he
understood what it means to be friends
by looking at what Scipio had to say
he says Scipio used to complain that men
were more painstaking in all other
things than in friendship and that
everybody could tell how many goats and
sheep he had but was unable to tell the
number of his friends so people are
sloppy they're loose they're kind of
lackadaisical when it comes to this
thing that's much more important and
they focus on the lesser you know what
we call the small stuff of how many
possessions they have how many goats are
sheep they have how many cattle they
have
you know and today we might think about
the person who's more focused on their
car and how many books they have on
their shelf or how many mp3s they have
in there their music player than they
are on the actual person in front of
them and this is very sad right for a
number of reasons that we'll talk about
he goes on and he says that they had no
certain signs or marks so to speak by
which to determine their fitness for
friendship that who could really be a
good friend and who could not so they
they pick people who aren't very good
for them they select people who are not
going to be good friends and they select
them on the basis of some sort of
temporary expediency or some imagined
help that's going to come down the line
and there's never really close
connection or if there is it's it's
solely on the basis of chance happening
to get lucky not actually able to you
know work this out in in in thoughtful
coherent way so that's an important
criticism right there let's look at
another thing that Cicero has Laelius
say in here what we can call the example
of the tyrant now a Greek tyrant doesn't
just mean somebody who's a bully who
Lords it over other people in talking
about the tyrant we mean somebody who's
successful in doing so successful to the
degree that they can rule an entire
political community whether it be a city
or he might even have somebody like
Caesar in mind here an entire empire
right a republic a vast array of
people's or anybody in between maybe the
Persian Great King could be seen as a
kind of tyrant Alexander the Great
certainly certainly behaved in
tyrannical ways when he got power so
this is this is a very important aspect
we might also think about people who
rise to the top in whatever organization
that they're
maybe maybe it's a genuine meritocracy
and they happen to subvert it or maybe
it just happens to be based on status
and prestige and wealth and all those
sorts of things and they buy their way
to the top or their privileged enough or
they're just ruthless as hell and they
get there and they run a company or they
run an educational institution or
whatever it happens to be
these are tyrants these are people who
are in a particularly good position with
respect to certain kinds of goods but
not the most important goods let's see
what he says here so he tells us who
would wish to be surrounded by unlimited
wealth and to abound in every material
blessing on this condition on condition
that he loved no one and no one loved
him so you know he's got all the wealth
no love and he says this is indeed as
the life of a tyrant I mean in which
there can be no faith no fides no
affection no Licari toss no trust in the
continuance of goodwill where every act
arouses suspicion and anxiety and where
friendship has no place he goes on and
he says can anyone love either the man
who he fears or the man who by whom he
believes himself to be feared tyrants
are courted only under a pretence of
affection but only for a season when
they fall from power as they generally
do it's known how poor they were in
friends so you know do we actually want
to live like this well some people do
some people in fact value the things and
buy things we have the wide range of
possible goods which which are genuine
goods but are not the good itself and
they prioritize those over people and
they preclude themselves from enjoying
the kind of relationship that a real
friendship would have they're not going
to have goodwill because people only
want them to do well so that they can
get things from them they really can't
have
any trusting relationships everybody
might be out to get them and this is a
really miserable way to to live as many
people have actually said throughout
history quite a few people who are
tyrants in this way don't realize that
until they want a friend to share things
with and or even a romantic partner and
can't find one who won't take advantage
of them who won't soak them for whatever
they can get so you know this is this is
a great example and going on a little
bit there's this discussion of the
foolishness of procuring the things that
wealth he says what is more foolish when
men are in the plenitude of resources
opportunities and wealth when you do in
fact have things to procure the other
things which money provides and here he
gives examples of horses slaves splendid
raiment that's that's clothing and
costly plate you know your dinner dishes
now we might say all sorts of other
things yachts wonderful you know media
you know resources buying followers and
friends in social media yeah we could go
on and on and on right why do people
spend the money that they have and the
other resources like opportunities or
contacts on getting things rather than
on getting friends well it's because
they don't understand the value of
genuine friendship and although they may
desire the things that come from friends
the affection the goodwill they don't
desire them enough or they're mistaken
in thinking that if they can just become
successful if they could just have
enough money or you know if they're
balding or something getting their hair
restored or doing all sorts of things
with their body you know with
liposuction and plastic surgery or
hiring a trainer and getting really buff
and working out that somehow that's
going to translate into good
human relationships with friends none of
those have an intrinsic connection so
you know procuring the things that
wealth provides but not using that money
to procure friends and he says who are
if I may say so and he says something
kind of funny here life's best and
fairest furniture you know they're
really doing something foolish and he
says when they procure these material
things they don't know for whom they do
it nor for whose benefit they toil these
things are the prey of the strongest you
know if you become rich that can be
taken away from you if you get yourself
all sorts of entourage and people to
hang on your arms and you know make you
look good that can go away in a second
all of your followers in social media
could gravitate to somebody else all of
those things are rather ephemeral but if
you cultivate genuine friendships he
says then you know to every person the
tenure of their friendships remains
settled and sure so even if there should
be a continuance of those things which
are so to speak the gratuities of
fortune yet life unadorned and
unattended by friends could not be
pleasant so you know this is another
mindset thing as well
finally we want to think about people
who do have friends do they value the
friendship itself or are they only
valuing what they can get out of the
relationship which would again be
valuing things loving things more than
loving the persons themselves and
there's there's a discussion of this
here he talks about this is in section
21 he says that the majority of human
beings recognize nothing whatsoever in
human experience as good unless it
brings some sort of profit and they
regard their friends as they do their
cattle valuing most highly those who
give hope of the largest gain and now
this may be a little pessimistic about
friendship but we can think of many
people like this and he says what's the
problem with this I mean it's bad to do
that because you're you're using the
person you're probably doing it under
false pretenses calling them all my
beloved friend you know when you're
really just trying to get something out
of them but there's another cost Cicero
says thus they fail to attain that
loveliest most spontaneous friendship
which is desirable in and for itself and
there he talks about this loveliness
Pulkit or emo right and the the most
natural most spontaneous translated here
friendship they lack it and they don't
learn what this this could do he says
they don't learn from their own
experience what the power of such
friendship is and are ignorant of its
nature and extent it here this is a very
important point Cicero is highlighting
the fact that we can you know have a
treatise on friendship and talk all
about how great friendship is and do the
things that would prepare us as persons
to be able to love and love and be loved
in return and to develop this this
growing relationship but we also need to
experience it it's very important that
we be in actual relationships and from
them we learn experientially
experimentally what friendship really
can consistent so he goes on and he says
everyone loves himself not with a view
of acquiring some profit for himself
from his self-love but because he is
dear to himself on his own account
unless this same feeling is transferred
to friendship
the real friend would never be found for
he is as it were another self people who
love things more than they love persons
even if they happen to wind up in a
relationship with somebody else who
could be a genuine friend can't fully
recognize that sometimes until it's too
late
one has to have the right sort of
valuing or prioritization
of persons over other non personal goods
in order to be able to fully understand
friendship and appreciate it so again
this is a problem of mindset of behavior
and of effectivity that Cicero helps us
to understand and if we recognize
ourselves as sometimes prioritizing or
valuing things more than friends and we
understand that there's something wrong
with that we do have some hope of
turning ourselves away from that first
mistaken mindset and growing into a more
full personal oriented friendship that
would allow for you know the fullness of
what Cicero is sketching here as
friendship
you